there was a lot of criticism about that
first album
yeah and i can tell you why uh um um it
was very rushed
um uh
my manager stackquo which fun fact about
statquo he was uh the first artist
signed to shady aftermath with dr dre
and eminem
um so he has he was actually popping out
in like the early 2000s as a rapper but
that didn't work out for him so he went
behind the scenes and wanted to manage
artists and i was his first artist to
blow up
um
and uh [ __ ] i was just lost
yeah i mean it's okay like uh
i i felt like you were
saying you know why the album was
critical
yeah the the like oh yo it was rush what
if we just said you weren't sober you
didn't put in the work i wasn't sober uh
i didn't put in the work enough i mean
the color blind on it was good moonlight
on it was good uh basically all the
records that were already doing good
that were on the album
they were good songs on the album and
and a couple others but it was rushed
um
and i was on drugs and i feel like my
team i'm not blaming my team for this at
all it's you know but i feel like they
should have
it you know because they're powerful
people in the industry i feel like they
should have listened to this and been
like we should not put this out okay
that i mean
that's fair sadly they did put it out
you did put it out into your name on it
yeah um but you're [ __ ] blown up
because of it
well you were already you had blown up
already right you had blown up
when you signed the deal
what was your motivation to do that
because was it just a big sign bonus or
something for uh what first time with
columbia signing because you would
already because
my uh previous manager stat quo
was uh he was friends with uh uh jimmy
iveen's um nephew and they they they're
like columbia family so they wanted me
to just be
with them you know kind of stuff yeah
and i bring up the criticism of that
first album because like i think that
it's healthy to just acknowledge like
whatever the issue was
so that you can address it moving
forward because like you said you've got
you've got a bunch of music and it's
good music yeah because that album was
dropped in 2018 and and you know it's
been years and years since i've dropped
because i refuse to drop something
that's going to turn out like that again
you know what i mean right that's what i
want to hear do i want your next album
to be like [ __ ] it's no
it's like bro it's like it's like it's
like a mixture of rap and indie it's
kind of like indie indie and rap it's
got a lot more instruments and
presumably you recorded it before you
just went into rehab uh i've been
recording um for the last seven months
for this album yeah like in between
rehabs and stuff but it's sounding
really good there's some like a lot more
instruments a lot more like uh like
violins and pop punk stuff and i got you
know the typical bangers
and but uh more topics more
more lyricism more
but but but also retaining the little
xan style you know are you putting it
out on your own uh i believe i'm going
to put it out on my own yes
so you don't make any money up front
when you put it on your own right
there's no there's no advantage there's
no advance there are royalties but the
most important like like i said i'm
living comfortably but the most
important thing for me for this next
thing is just to show people how much
i've evolved and that i'm ready i'm
ready to play ball like and to be taken
serious you know because this next album
in my opinion is
i'm so proud of it i'm very proud of it
you know that's good and i can't i i
could make nothing off it i just want
them to know
like let's go you know what i mean you
guys got any features on it uh it's just
going to be just strictly me i just
wanted it it's not too late to add
features though right because i think i
think my my friend p and b rock who's a
big rapper might hop on a couple things
and uh
some low-key artist but for the most
part since it's self-titled my name i
kind of just want it to be you know just
mostly me
um and you know i started rapping again
is that what you're gonna say
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]